foreign
[Applause]
first shot of the game for the Canucks produces
goal number 29 for JT Miller and Vancouver
leads one nothing and you'll watch Thomas
hurdle throw this pass turns and just fires
it right to JT Miller that's an awful path
and what a shot by JT Miller up and over the
right shoulder of James Reimer
[Applause]
ricochies to the blue line and out and the
Canucks will have to tag up his bear controls
ahead to Patterson out of Mobility back for
Pederson cutting to the net centers [Applause]
[Music]
thank you pretty pretty passing and kuzmenko
has his 35th to double the lead [Applause]
Patterson [Applause] look at James Reimer
he is completely swimming on this one he's
down on both knees stretched out and kusbanko
doesn't waste the blocked shot goes to the
backhand and now time for the second longest
active streak with Clayton County
Nathan McKinnon
for his earlier mistake and hurdle cuts the
deficit in half we're talking about Eric Carlson
what a beautiful pass that was hurtle Off
the Bench you can see anything middle now
everybody's going and it almost looks like
the facts are trying to make a change it looks
like JT Miller was trying to get off the ice
and Thomas hurdle just Carlson brings the
puck ahead passes to count cutting in chemical
to save Carlson could have tied the assist
record for the Sharks right there
clumped down by Gregor back to hurdle cutting
in he shoots and he hit the post in it that
close to his second of the period and tying
the game Derek cullia hurdles got it got all
sorts of time through the screen it's by Thatcher
Demko and lebanc does a nice job on the screen
slides out of the way
there's another shot on Genco no rebound as
he takes the whistle Murph himself
feeds one ahead one last rush for the Canucks
champs for Joshua from the horn he scores
Dakota Joshua who had a goal scrub that would
he get him giving him a hat trick against
the Sharks earlier did he beat the bosser
or did he get it just a little bit too late
good passing on the line rush and you can
see the Sharks all get mesmerized
and they put four tenths on the clock so I
think it's gonna count it is it is there it
is fine
trucks are still at five defenseman there's
Christian malignant has not here for the second
period he played three shifts in the first
animal and then we're going to find out his
status and here's Pederson right off the draw
Stern defending without a stick Miller Peterson
Ola stopped by Reiner lunging to his left
and he's able to cover the puck as well said
he hasn't made one good thing here's kuznaku
in on the left Point what do you want it from
and tries couldn't quite reach the pass
foreign
[Music] [Applause] [Music]
try and Garland's the one who fires it around
and then he goes to that Tyler Meyer sees
him [Applause] yeah it goes right to Connor
dial and he's smart enough not just to slide
it back down towards Miller let's look who
in the corner his pass picked off flosser
tried to move it it was stolen in front besser
stop Point Blank sharks coughed this one up
Mark Edward Vlasic on the pressure from kuzmenko
and Brock besser is in so tight it's tipped
well done Parker thanks Mako had to go off
the skate here come the Sharks potential two
on one magazino to the net scores short-handed
goal for San Jose their fourth of the year
the 12th surrendered by Vancouver which ties
him for the most in the league with Detroit
and it's a 4-2 game in the entry here's Andre
kuzbenko goes off his stick and now it's a
two on one and he can't get his man and so
the shot it is over Thatcher Demko what a
great shot that is
second game of the year he had an assist in
the first one he gets a short-handed goal
in this one it's his first goal there's a
shot [Applause]
right back as the silly Park Falls and rifles
that one in 15 seconds after agnesino made
it four to two well here's the silly pot golden
right up the middle takes the pass cuts to
the middle let's go and that just beats James
Reimer you can see him looking at his love
rate all over his left ear a great shot by
the 75 goals and it just absolutely handcuffs
James Reimer and beat San Jose for the ninth
straight time GT Miller there's a full 360
in the corner against the puck back Hughes
long shot [Music] [Applause]
[Music] they're all looking around to see
who got it I think Phil de Giuseppe is the
guy that got a stick on it it's two and let's
have a look here's Queen using he just snaps
this one gets a snap and there's the Giuseppe
standing in front he gets it up and over James
reimer's left shoulder good eyes yep right
off the blade hey yeah Reimer is the chance
here's the chance at the end of the blocker
being robbed magazino looking for his second
of the period
perhaps up breaks up the play inside the blue
line and now it's going to put off the post
almost had another one there funny play it's
off a couple of sticks up and over James they
need to kill this one and then the next one
here's di Giuseppe drives cutting towards
the goal backhander scores [Music] short-handed
goal of the year for the Canucks they tie
Edmonton for first in the NHL his drives makes
it 7-2 and Bill D Giuseppe with the play good
hustle steals apocal backhand passage Sheldon
drives forehand back and James Reimer didn't
react he bit on the forehand fake [Applause]
shoots blocked and that's gonna do as Ethan
bear got into the way of that last Puck throw
it on goal and thatchered into it and celebrate
his career against the San Jose Sharks